So Good everyone and I would like to by
thanking the organizers of bi conference
Life for giving me This Opportunity to
Present some of ours to this audience
so we have a long last expertise in cell
biology molecular biology biochemistry
and in recent Times We decided to try  to
capitalize All this expertise and
background for the Development of no
therapeutic approaches for
different cancers and also some
developmental
diseases I'm talking Today some develops
that we
in to BL
cancer
so essentially the blad as an
organ it has a Series Of advantages and
disadvantages  for the treatment of
cancer
eh as an
Advantage we have the ability to only
Hit the
as BL the content of the BL is
constantly diluted by the influx of
urine and then there ising of the BL
Which eliminate therapeutic been Into the
BL Most of the BL  cancer
Beer
do
in ep
Lay the
BL as indicated Before The Blood has
advantages and disadvantages for the
treatment of cancer and it Has to do
with the specific Architecture of the
blad so the
epithelium essentially has an aner layer
Which is the m
differentiated layer of cells Which  are
umbrella cells So This umbrella cells
are making tight junctions so They also
produce a layer of proteins in the
apical Surface Which are called Europ
plins Which Sort of create a certain
Armor for the cells to protect them from
the harsh environment of the urine On
Top  Of that these differentiated cells
produce a glycos Amin glycon layer Which
actually produces a very effective
Barrier
Prot cells from from the environ of
BL When T Ares out of the epithelium
These cells Are Less differentiated so
therefore They don't produce much of Ty
junctions and  they don't produce much of
glycin glyc layer and they don't Express
much Europ so These cells Are mostly
exposed to the Lumen of the blad So This
Present a Unique Opportunity to Hit the
bad Guys without affecting The Good Guys
Which remain protected by  the G layer
and by the euring Armor
so However When we try to Hit these
cells with noned
approaches for example rub any other
Comp no targeted Therapeutics we are
dealing with the of as dilution of Drug
With The Constant influx of the urine
and also with the  voiding of the blad So
This compound will be eliminated Each
Time That the BL voids so definitely is
challenging the to Comes from the
AG
so The Good cells are
protected the glyc
Lay and the formation of junctions We
need to be that
Conc
th the future in  this
respect Cas we obviously realiz I
meaning of the Blood theion of would
affect
Affinity concentration of the Agent the
T
cells the bacterium of the tuberculosis
so As You Many of you May know This is
actually
the the Therapy of Choice nowadays for
the treatment of superficial  blad cancer
essentially What Happens is that BCG
Will directly interact with the tumor
cells and and essentially will be Taken
by microcytosis
and the antigen Will beed
imm BCG immune resp produc contribute to
the Elimination of the tumor
cells Never we know BCG has certain
drawbacks essentially Has  certain
morbidity the tolerance decreases With
The Use the pa
more
tocc course bacter the ris of systemic
infe does occur so wean
wean be careful about That So so
then the Question Is What can we
do to replace pcg So one possibility
Came out from the Research provided  by
the Rat Lab Team
Rat Lab Which was the identification of
the fibc attach
This is the protein that is responsible
for BCG attachment to tumor cells So
essentially This protein recognizes cell
ftin and it allows the bacterium to to
stick to the
cells so then the possibilities  are to
use directly this This protein is
nontoxic and
immunogenic
has characteristics and n of the bad
characteristics and There is there is a
p about The Use of these and in the
right flb so So This Is This is an
ongoing Direction um So What We're
talking about this essentially The Use
of Fat as a substitute for BCG treatment
and essentially we could we can and we
do produce F as a recombinant protein
here in this cartoon You can see his
tagged Fap so suggesting that this is a
recombinant in The L  produced Fat that
combine to fibronectin which in Turn is
Return on the Surface of the cells by
binding to two integrators so So This is
just substitute Therapy but we can
actually Dream of more we can actually
Dream of the possibility of using of
targeting agent in a  Primary Therapy
that means the for example One
possibility is to use
decorated Nan liposomes Will loaded
Toxic payload to
actually Cure the the tumor
cells so essentially the idea Will Be
to have These Fat decorated
nanoparticles nano liposomes Which
essentially will be loaded with with a
Poison of  some Sort and they will
be targeting the tumor cells and upon
delivery of the cytotoxic load Kill the so That's
over strategy now the successful
design of Such strategy need to address
a few Points the first thing is that
these cells tumor
cells BL tumor cells Show a  very
Selective
and Low and Slow endocytosis for other
Things the They are interested in so We
need to address that Point and Of course
any Therapy need to know if it can involve
uptake And internalization We need to
know the details of that tic pathway so
That the design  reflects the the
characteristics of the pathway is
adapted to to take Advantage of of this
pathway so the first thing that We did
was to try to address this Challenge of
the Low and Slow endocytosis by T cells
and for
that we start first by using some of  Our
biology expertise to actually look at
How FB interacts with CB FIB so for that
and and I'm gna be using this can
techniques All Over the presentation Now
We use several approaches so We use on
One Side the detection of bap by by
using antibodies  Against
his recombinant protein Orly antif
antibodies so These antibodies will be
either Will recognize bound Fat and Will
use either a secondary Label With
fluorescent prob or even the ths Lab
here developed a probe which recognizes
the nta nickel nta
Flor way we we can
even bypass  The need for an antibody and
Just use nickel nta That is fluorescent
to Label Fat and Of course We will use
other antibodies directed towards other
Elements of the Sand for example integr
or
fibc
so here You can see some of the results
that We originally obtained so  in
this Panel Here towards the left we
can
see Flap and and the
arrows Point out to certain areas of
colocalization
with fibronectin Which you see in the
Middle Panel so an anti antif was used
to to Stain the cells this this Panel
and one of
the  methods for Det was Used in the left
Panel and you can see in the right Panel
the overlapping of both Images
essentially The Arrow only some there
are multiple
other Lines of colocalization so Fat
does bind FIB under conditions I should
say the
usal
fibroblast We did that  our purp is to
talk about explore nov therapeutic canc
the reason is because setting up the
conditions we want some cells that Will
produce robust
fibc network and Cas of
fibroblast you in my foll slid We then
Move to t24 Human BL cancer cells also
We
use
Another  construct Which is the version
of Which has
been modified to eliminate the Fi
binding and you can see it in the Lower
Row Delta 213 216 it eliminates binding
and As you
canalization is
l Of course We also tried the
colocalization of with other Elements of
the sandwich  and here You can see the
colocalization with Beta One integr And
there is a significant colocalization
between and between the Beta
integr As I said I mean this was
essentially using
Fast
ISS Use of BL tum cell We That the of
and SL less developed in this Less
differentiated cell but nevertheless I
hope you can see in the in the left
Panel particular in the in the zoom in
areas That decorates the Surface of
cells and these structures
coc with F so seems to be Working
perfectly fine in this hum BL tumor
cells so If  we want to develop a Primary
Therapy that Will lead to the Delivery
of some cytotoxic payload so We need to
We need to have endocytosis so in a
typical internalization
experiment so essentially what you do is
you allow your your CS to interact with
the with the probe  with Whatever Prot
You are looking at for
internalization allow internalization to
occur so then some of
These molecules Are gna be in an in
Cellular compartment and some others
will remain on the
Surface usually People do an acidic Wash
or some other Can washes to strip off
the  uninter fraction and then
essentially all Signal that Remains
associated with cells
represents the
internalized fraction as Well so So This
is the way In which We usually do
internalization Experiments so Now Good
news and Bad news from F So What So What
we is that is
associated with
Long
ph as we all know the
urine BL cancer patients is AIC and
ph
4.8.5 and that means will be Will ATT
theet That's Good now the bad news is
that
How
ATT We to develop a New approach to to
determine the fraction of internal so We
use our first trick trick number one and
is to Vis the internal essentially
We is the Fact foll
internation like rap Five Are requir For
the Fusion of
endend vesicles with the endosomal
compartment so If you Express and this
is Long known in the field of biology a
constitutively Active rap q79 l Mutant
essentially this Mutant Which is also
Label with gfp leads to the formation of
Giant
because
V
generates endosomes Which are because
gfp tag are going to be Green So This is a
way for us to see the
internalized is
internalized
greenell
structur
SL  the content of endosomal structures
to the lysosomal compartment So This
part of the traffic event from the green
structures to the
lysos Slow Down by the Presence
of that leads to the accumulation of in
incell
structur so Side positive Effect Of The
Use of This construct Is it  increases
the sensitivity for us to detect
internalized So we did some Experiments
in of that Sort and essentially we used
the 24 cells in culture at on CS
expressing the the Mutant
WAP Active and I hope you can see the
All Green circular structures
representing structures so also  what you
seeing here are some arrows that Point
out to
certain endosomes that do contain F
Inside You can see that very well in the
in the merge image You can see that F is
Inside of this endosome structure so That's
great so So we have internalization so
that was easier
however was norm conditions of cell
culture
so including serum and all the other
supplies was a good first attt but that
Doesn't resemble The environment of the
BL and you be surprised How many papers
were published in
binding BL
in pres of ser
is in concentrations in the in the Lum
of the blad So we decided to try to
emulate the conditions of the blad a
little bit Better So we Try To Begin
with conditions and even In The Presence
of instillation
buffer under Those conditions
unfortunately There is no
internation  As You can see in
is of
CS and explanation is that serum is
filled with growth factors Which induce
microcytosis and other Fluid phase
events that will take in So What do we do
Now So we Dev trick Number Two Which
is essentially to promote
internalization essentially for
peopley Field to Prom the clustering of
bound receptors using for example
antibodies so If you use an
antibody Just due to the balency It will
Just Bring two complexes together If you
use a polyclonal
This
microcer is expanded so goes Beyond
andu More and
Morea micr area and  this is a prerequis
for internalization so and actually
That's what we predict will Happen so by
using this polyclonal antibodies We will
trigger endocytosis and this Of course
is the object of the patent that we have
so actually trick you a little bit the
image i show you  before was not Just
of serum also in Presence of irr anti
anti Now If you use relevant anti for
example an antif antibody instead of an
irrelevant One essentially what you see
is what is shown here so you see a
clustering of fap and actually Very
interesting Those  clusters do cocal with
the endosomal structures i desb before
So we have signant colocalization
with endom structures You can also One
Little example
here Cluster that has not been
internalized Just Yet So This is very
exciting So we can control endocytosis
of that events was also confirmed by
using other approaches
including dete
Another
the predictions of this approach This
mechanism is
that be dependence with the anti Dil
so concentration
lti interaction of
is
moderate very low
however If you increase the
concentration so talking
about change in the
dilution
Lil
internation increases If you go even
further in the concentration so then you
find a further decrease in the
internalization of this is due to the
fact that There is no Much microc
clustering Anymore but actually There is
Each antibody finds the target so There
is no clustering There is no
crosslinking of Complex Being  form So
This is according to the
predictions the mechanism
weed
This is goods as because suggest that in
Hours Which is
usually Time frame for treatment of BL
cancer patients we have
signation
meanly
manyes exemplified
and routes for internalization and
obviously the most famous of all is the
Independent pathway so that was the one
the first one that We tried
so and to do that
toil
ocy ir and essentially what you are
seeing here is that When we knock
down clattering Heavy
Chain the Critical component for clat
endocytosis is not affected in ITS
internalization on  the other Hand
typical clattering dependent Cargo like
transfering is sely affected by Heavy
Chain knockdown so suggesting That the
approach Works is just the F is
insensitive to to the CL remediated
pathway So This Suggests that this
clattering Independent So we looked at
the other subgroup of pathways  and and
we particularly Focus on the second more
famous endocytosis mechanism Which is
the one mediated by cavioli so so We use
the same approach once again and when we
knock down
CL Med
car transf is not affected When cavioli
is
knock definitely cavioli
cons
gets
but  we also some colocalization
Experiments and I hope you can see here
That
cocal seen in in the cling light
CH Channel So essentially we see the F
After binding To The cells cocal with
cabbage structures and you can see some
other examples here And there
so So What  we know now is that gets
internalized by cavioli media pathway
and the question
traff Comp So we
know the data was included in prev SL
didn't discuss the recycling Doesn't
seem to be an important
rout We sign recycl
plase
and
traff for that Try  to
see prog to a l two
compartment l two is the lysosomal
associated membrane prote a Mar of the
compartment and here You can see the
results essentially this
and and as can there
We use once again transfer CL dependent
Cargo And We use transfer because
transfer is  known to recycle Back To The
plasma membrane and As You can see
Doesn't Reach the degr compartment so I
hope you can see here That the
sign Sign transf there
isocal we have a signant colocalization
depicted by the yellow color in between
and the Mar that  Could Be quantified and
it was significant the difference
respect to Random colocalization and we
even Look at the the kinetic of
colocalization
and Max colocation
andav our
object Based on the targeted delivered of
liposomes so So What About That So to to
resume where we left So This  is part of
the design We Said We need to
address the Challenge of Low and Slow
endocytosis We did that by promoting
micr clustering and also We needed to
know some characteristics of thetic
pathway and we figure that cabbage Med
How use worn
so As I the Challenge  Slow lyos was
added As I showed you
by FIB inte complexes using anti So This
brings
in the
Point
in the Comp Will work to Prom ocos soti
we thought we could potentially
micr Comp Us anti
Us
Nan
micr
Poly on the other Hand We also figure As
I show you that the internalization Path
involved in this uptake of wasol
Med Because the end vesic and Car
the
nci use 50
nanomet particles with Space on 10
nanomet in average on the Surface the
prediction was that these
characteristics of the design Will lead
to the uptake  of
particles We prep liposomes with
characteristics and
We a signant
upt
in here Excuse what you see here are
liposomes Which Are Flor themselves so
some of the lipid are fluorescent and
therefore you see the lipos and again we
have our 5 gfp
po
in
All containing liposomes  As a control As
You can see here we are also using
liposomes Which
We dec and I hope you can see There is
sign
ntic BL
CS so further so excuse me so here You
can see quantitation of what I just said
so in the absence of F  There is no
uptake significant uptake while In The
Presence of There is a significant
uptake of the
lios
good the
other
Taken that goes the mechanism that web
before and sugg Same
tot
theom internation
is
loos Dr in cas here You can see
essentially the control no Fat  so the
cells by themselves In The Presence of
Fat no particular difference There is no
Carrier Nan Carrier in this
case and when we do
Use
drad
lios
we have Sign
Killing
cell so in summary what I show you today
is strategy that We Dev to induce the
uptake of Fat in in a control Man so I
think That's a very important Point here
we
canol the uptake
of we determine
byol mechanism and reaches the
compartment and we further prove that
liposomes can be decorated with F andb
Will promote the
internalization by BL T cells
so with that I would like close and
Thank you for attending
you that There is Education credits that
you can by going to this Link to the
conference Thank you very much and
answer some questions
If
So we have a question here about the
How antibodies can  generate an immune
resp May
nanoparticles this Delivery Method tget
micr This is a very good Question so
something that We need to remember is
that
Delivery
anti anti Us first as as a tool Just to
test the idea of
crosslinking but We need to remember
that nevertheless these  nanoparticles
are in in the Lum of the blad so They
are not in the
Blood They are mostly on completely On
The luminal Side so they will be Just
bating the
cells from the luminal side so so al
possible that in in further steps of the
treatment there  might be a Contact with
some of the cells from the immune System
at the very Beginning that that
shouldn't
Happen I Hope That that answer the
Question otherwise I will be happy to
further discuss this topic
any other
question
some other Question here about what is
the composition of the liposomes Cic or
others I don't from Top of my head right
now eh I don't think the are
Cic but I Apologize I don't remember
that I refer you to a paper We publish
in International Journal of cancer  co at
all co
all and you May Find the the actual
concentration there the composition
there Apologize don't
remember
question
Another Question
can We saw
this successful internalization
ofg by producing this microc clustering
so others as Well
including some artificial that we are
creating so yeah  it seems like the
microc of bound
receptors is a viable meth
ind
Another Question asking inv data for F
particles So we are generating that data
right now
ands
any Fur
questions is no more questions Thank you
for attending this seminar so and
Please don'  t to contact me
for
clarifications to my email address so be
happy any Question After so
good